the film lands most glamorous stars has
been invited to present the awards for
custom design the lovely Miss Jean
Tierney
those nominated for achievement in
costume design of black and white
production are the actress
metro-goldwyn-mayer miss Phyllis
Applegate is wearing one of the costumes
designed by Walter Plunkett dream white
metro-goldwyn-mayer Helen Rose and
Herschel McCoy
Marjorie Malloy is modeling one of the
gowns From Here to Eternity Columbia
Holly the model is Kim Novak the
president's lady 20th Century Fox
Charles the mayor and Renee the model is
Gloria Gordon Roman Holiday paramour
Edith Head the model is Marla English
for achievement in costume design for
production in black and white Edith head
for Roman holiday
for achievement in costume design for a
color production the nominees are the
bandwagon Metro golden mayor Mary Ann
Nyberg the marble is their ashamed
call me madam 20th Century Fox Irene
Cara and McCree is the model how to
marry a millionaire 20th Century Fox
Charles the mayor and trivia Joan Weldon
in the model the robe 20th Century Fox
Charles the mayor and Emily pardon me
Emile Santiago the marble is Virginia
deep and young death Metro golden mayor
Walter Plunkett Barbara Dara was wearing
one of the gals the envelope please
Charles LA mayor and mu Santiago for the
robe
thank you very much
I think she's more excited in there